Counter Strike global Offensive is by
definition a first-person shooter that
means that incredible aim is at the core
of what makes the game so excited
Grenada if there are a ton of damage LG
make that round to the bomb site oh but
look at flame he's ready take it down -
but at the top level strategy is
incredibly important to having the right
tactics for a map can be the difference
between victory or defeat olofmeister is
still waiting the patience game coming
again spot them coming out squeak torch
while he's here he sees them now they're
straight headshot they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed
you've gotta be kidding me take stock
here shame retro and math mastery comes
in the form of strategies often ones
that rely on utility that means grenades
flashbangs of Molotov and smooth all
designed to force enemies out of
position in the 9m sight line and bring
it to the one-on-one as soon as the ball
was planted now the element of surprise
gone but still he's able to push through
books is not ready for it this comes
back through toward window the get backs
it off he's got a smoke he's got the
kick but if he goes immediately on top
of it Lucas is gonna play aggressive so
they can't hold it you might have gotten
away with it but there's no sense
chancing it if he still has time wants
on closer side this is gonna be the hole
because it's gonna force him back he's
got the wide shot around he's protected
all the top
[Applause]
to force out the time in position but
sometimes a player will do something
that subverts expectations and no player
embodies that more than simple in
counter-strike there are individuals
that have made a name for themselves by
defying conventions for example in a 1v1
against Kenny ass at ESEA LAN 13 North
American CS prodigy swag through his
pistol to fake a flashbang
Kenny turned away from the impending
blast that never came and he cleaned up
Kenny for the clutch one-on-one year
with swag swag full health still has an
8 if he spots him and be able to go up
the nade here no reason to peek he saw
him yeah so let's go take the x-ray
around a down so we can build up to
suspense here all of you at home are
probably hating me right now oh he picks
him off great job I sweat so I make sure
I turn McNichol a fantastic play there
swag the young gun so crafty and I
actually worked he turned around he got
him full dedicated to look away from
that North American CS Pro Stewie 2k
also famously disregards expectations of
the game instead of consciously playing
around the smoke like most players he
aggressively pushes through it often
catching players who expect him to be
cautious off guard
renegades down to a two-on-two jks with
a quick shot and Stewie the bombs not
for him they may not have the kit player
on the bomb so jks swaps with the smoke
down was Joey he's come for the knife
he's gonna go for it he does it Joey he
might find this clutch and he goes again
for more it's trading back and forth
let's do him he finds the clutch she
finds a round and cloud nine with a
second pistol for cloud 9 as such so
he's gonna get aggressive with his AWP
had to do so slips in behind the
forklift it gets away with it get back
to the site and finds fallen as well
bomb goes down
he is unrelenting pushing through the
smoke line and they're gonna have no
idea where this hop is Stewie brilliant
but simple known for his confidence and
the skills that back it up
is one of the game's most exciting
players CC he comes in smokes
double smokes in the same place this is
absolutely unbelievable he's the
x-factor per team liquid there is no
question there is just a little age of
something different about simple that
makes you think I actually believe this
collection and simple like every grape
refuses to accept the limitations of the
expectations put upon him by others and
that's led to some incredible highlights
ready and waiting simple vote just
doesn't see the camera he's throwing the
rulebook on us right away and he's
completely lighting him up this is
unbelievable simple we've had shots from
hell and here's the one New York 2016 a
tournament simple and Navi would go on
to win he made a fateful decision in a
1v1 against Team Liquid nitro down into
a one-on-one good trades but it's simple
and he's already here right outside
smoke gonna go off simple on the other
side he pulls out the pistol he's got
the p250
close range it's a one-shot nitro he's
got a triple he fakes it once and just
goes to check the window this is all
about timing nitro does have a lot of
another smoke so could be really rough
for simple times to get through this
he's gotta throw the a double
[Applause]
if it is that in a shocking move simple
through the awp a sniper rifle worth
four thousand seven hundred and fifty
dollars over the wall into dust tooth
beam bomb site sometimes you will see
someone strong their pistol to pretend
it's a grenade to have people turn
around but what do you think it was
gonna be a nest right coming in with a
missile from the sky was simply actually
doing the exact effect this had on the
1v1 is still a matter of debate it
wouldn't be unreasonable for a player in
nitros position to be distracted by the
incoming flying object then again he
didn't seem to react too dramatically to
it but throwing the world's most
expensive flashbang is perfectly in line
with simples audacious nature he was
preying on others expectations and won
the duel because of it it was just like
wait you know he's like what the [ __ ] is
going on
of course given the sheer flashiness of
the play there were plenty of people who
wanted to recreate it to varying degrees
of success
[Music]
and of course it wasn't the first time
somebody threw an AWP but it was the
first time it happened on a stage of
this size I think that's on the put on
the pro level tier 1 level I think that
the fight flash thing works one in maybe
a fifty or a hundred times even saw him
throwing his gun to do it it's just a
more of a psychological thing than
anything else because think of how much
that insult to injury to nitro as long
as there's an established way to play CS
there will always be cunning opponents
who exploit these patterns mortals now
feeling like they know what to do two
challenges put on a position the gambit
is send even more firepower bets bring
more it's huge in the corner
get blamed on goes yeah with the don't
that's so smart and in October 2016
simple reminded us why those
expectations can be a liability and how
they can let the OP double as a $4,750
flashbang simple times to get through
this he's go through the if it is that
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button